Do you have a protocol for fibromyalgia?
No, no.
So, the reason why it all,
because there's reasons why a person would have the symptoms of fibromyalgia.
fibromyalgia is not a disease in itself.
fibromyalgia is a collection of symptoms.
It's a syndrome.
So, you have to figure out why a person has this collection of symptoms.
Do they have an autoimmune issue?
So, they have antibodies to self-tissue.
Very common.
They have antibodies to collagen.
They have antibodies to their,
to their, you know, upper motor neuron, brain issue.
So, running labs that will look for antibodies to self-tissue
would be in order.
Also, with fibromyalgia, you could have some sort of chronic infection.
The chronic Lyme type issue can be an issue with fibromyalgia.
So, you don't want to,
and I'd recommend this with,
but just about everything,
there's, you don't want to go to somebody who's just going to,
here's my, here's my fibromyalgia protocol.
Or, here's this protocol for this disease.
I'm not saying somebody might not be helped by that,
but, you know, you have to get to the reason why.
You're just going to dig to the reason why,
and try to figure that out,
and then treat the reason why.
You've got treating the name disorder,
or name syndrome, or name disease.
Unfortunately, that's, that is really what is,
it's happening in the practice of medicine.
No, I mean, everybody's just a disease.
So, the idea of medicine is we come to the name of the disease,
and then we look up at Merck manual,
and we give this drug for that disease.
Well, is it treating the reason why the disease is there?
No, it's not typically treating why the disease is there.
It's not addressing the reason why.
Well, are you helping the patient?
Well, the drug may effectively decrease that person's symptoms,
but just because you've decreased the person's symptoms,
doesn't mean that you've effectively helped that person
with overall morbidity and issues with mortality for that disease.
I don't know, I think it's best to look and try to dig in
to figure out the reason why.